[Applause]
[Music]
japan has a somewhat special
relationship with its east asian
neighbors you can call it complicated or
even stormy here on visualpolitik we
have talked about it on several
occasions and the common reason is
always the same the historical quarrels
that time and again return like a
boomerang to political news but as
always there are exceptions one country
in particular which also suffered from
japan's colonial past nevertheless has
very good relations with the land of the
rising sun two countries that are
forging a close alliance with
significant implications for the entire
region an alliance not only in the
economic arena where in the end more or
less everyone understands each other but
also in the political one and pay
attention because surprisingly we are
talking about taiwan
[Music]
and i say surprisingly because we cannot
forget that behind everything is the
ever watchful eye of china for the asian
giant anything that has to do with
taiwan becomes a grievance and of course
china is the largest client of the
japanese economy japanese companies have
invested more than 130 billion dollars
in foreign direct investment in the
people's republic and the chinese
account for almost 30 percent of all
tourists who visit the land of the
rising sun each year so i don't know in
theory taking the risk of dumping the
asian giant well what can i say it
doesn't seem like a good idea but what
exactly brings japan and taiwan together
what exactly has made tokyo want to get
so close to taipei what are they looking
for well in this video we're going to
answer these questions and yes as many
of you can probably guess the growing
nationalist agenda of xi jinping has a
lot of influence in this whole story but
that's not all growing ties between
japan and taiwan are not just defined by
having a common adversary in some ways
we are talking about an alliance rooted
in economic social and even for better
or worse a shared history
[Music]
you see although the former san
authorities share with mainland china
the claim to the senkaku islands which
are currently administered by japan
there is no hostility in the foreign
policy between taiwan and japan quite to
the contrary taiwan which was also once
occupied and colonized by the empire of
japan was one of the few colonies if not
the only one where there was little
internal resistance to the occupation in
fact it was probably also the occupied
territory with the largest number of
collaborators with the japanese and even
today many people in taiwan still have
fond memories of colonization a period
in which taiwan managed to become the
richest territory in all of east asia
with the exception of course of japan
itself for example during this period
the island saw a tenfold increase in the
number of kilometres of railway lines
and the japanese developed significant
electrical power on the island to boost
their textile and chemical industries
and thanks in large part to this taiwan
began its industrialization much earlier
than most other asian countries as a
result taiwanese industry underwent
significant development during the first
half of the 20th century although the
second world war meant that most of the
japanese legacy was completely lost
[Music]
what's more it could be said that
despite the heavy-handed repression of
political dissent the torture and
summary executions that always
characterize the japanese empire taiwan
was the darling of all its colonies
the fact is that all this shared history
goes a long way toward explaining why
taiwan officially the republic of china
had much less difficulty establishing
friendly diplomatic relations with
post-war japan these relations have
united these two countries in a kind of
symbiosis so marked that for many taiwan
is kind of like a chinese sister of
japan but what are japan's interests
with taiwan where are relations between
the two countries heading and will
japan's policies toward china change in
favour of taiwan well listen up
japan taiwan friendship mutual interest
on the map they may seem far away but
the truth is that less than 68 miles
that's 110 kilometers off the coast is
the closest point between japan and
taiwan specifically the island of
yonaguni and a little farther away about
137 miles 220 kilometers is the island
of ishigaki where japan is planning to
build the closest military base to
communist china yes that's right japan
has decided to build a major military
installation less than 140 miles from
taiwan quite the letter of intent can
you imagine if they had decided to set
up a base so close to south korea what a
mess that would have been but we'll talk
about this later in more depth the fact
is that the taiwanese far from getting
angry or feeling threatened are
delighted i'm sure you can all imagine
why nevertheless it is still striking
that japan is making such a gesture and
for those of you wondering no japan
doesn't officially recognize taiwan
either
june 2021 japan says ties with taiwan
are only unofficial of course that
hasn't stopped the ties between the two
territories from growing since japan
stopped officially recognizing the
former's ant government
[Music]
it was in 1972 that japan formally
ceased to recognize the republic of
china which is what taiwan is officially
called in favor of recognizing the
people's republic of china as the
legitimate government of all of china
however these nods to communist china
that were being made by most countries
in the world did not really have any
consequences for the day-to-day workings
of the country companies continue to
relocate production to taiwan taking
advantage of the relatively cheaper
labor force and they achieved a very
important position in its industrial
fabric and not only that japan was also
present in taiwan as a major investor
during taiwan's industrial
transformation in the 1970s taiwan went
from textile factories to petrochemical
factories and in the 1980s and the 1990s
it managed to develop a powerful it
industry particularly in hardware and
very specifically in semiconductors in
all these cases japanese capital was
decisive
interestingly in the case of
semiconductors taiwan has managed to
beat japan comfortably it is the
foremost and country and now has the
upper hand to the extent that the
inverse scenario to the one that has
historically occurred could occur
industrial relocation from taiwan to
japan
tsmci's opening japan chip plant in 2023
to supply sony for those of you who
don't know tsmc is the largest and most
advanced semiconductor manufacturer in
the world and yes it's taiwanese
[Music]
semiconductors are the key the backbone
the heart and brain of new technologies
robotics nanotechnology autonomous
driving 5g and modern military systems
everything depends on semiconductors and
taiwan is the great world leader and of
course if you don't want to let china
become the sole and undisputed leader in
the region technology plays a key role
in this respect greater economic
integration between japan and taiwan
could have enormous geoeconomic
advantages together both countries would
be very well positioned to lead the
technological race in the region with
all that this implies and take note
because this could be key for the future
of the asia pacific and above all for
the role of the united states in this
area we cannot deny that both japan and
taiwan are great allies of washington so
it's all said and done integration
between the two countries is increasing
another example in terms of
infrastructure taiwan's first high-speed
railway was put into service in early
2007 and its trains network and
technology were directly imported from
japan
in fact the trains used for the high
speed line of the thsr 700t model and
manufactured by a consortium of kawasaki
hitachi and nipponshario subsidiaries
are an adapted version of the japanese
shinkansen and of course they also
adapted japanese technology to the line
side note this was the first time japan
had exported its high-speed rail
technology to a foreign country and as
you can see the fact that it was to
taiwan was by no means a coincidence the
project was so complex that it would be
a topic of its own on mega projects to
give you an idea it was built 100 from
scratch and 70 of the route runs over
viaducts taiwan invested 16.5 billion
dollars in that line mind you 79 was
born by a private investment and very
importantly take note wasteful
politicians of the world this line is
one of the few high speed lines in the
world that is profitable over 8 billion
new taiwanese dollars net profit in
2019. this equates to around 300 million
us dollars well wait a moment because
obviously there is much much more
because it is in matters of defense and
geopolitics that the relationship
between these two countries really
reaches its peak a union that is as
strong as it is informal but solid
nonetheless and it seems japan has
important plans for taiwan or maybe for
itself but it doesn't matter because
they directly benefit the island claimed
by china listen up
the ishigaki plan
[Music]
take a look at this map for a moment
this is the ryukyu island chain the
westernmost islands of japan among which
there is one that we have to highlight
in this video ishigaki
[Music]
why is that because in addition to being
one of the main tourist destinations in
okinawa prefecture apart from the island
of okinawa itself ishigaki is also a
strategic island for japan located just
a stone throws away from taiwan and very
close to mainland china but far enough
away not to be overly exposed ishigaki
could be japan's next strategic military
stronghold it is there that the japanese
self-defense forces plan to deploy both
anti-ship missiles and anti-aircraft
missiles between late 2022 and march
2023 as well as a contingent of between
500 and 600 soldiers to operate them all
of this with the excuse the excuse of
protecting the senkaku or dlu islands
from chinese provocations
[Applause]
however the reality could be different
the fact of having a military contingent
so close to taiwan has been seen by the
latter as a clear message of protection
to the island nation while at the same
time protecting japan itself and if
necessary it could even be a base of
operations for the united states
japan missile plan on ishigaki island
helps boost taiwan defense analysts say
the plan is aimed as much at defending
taiwan as japan as any attack on the
democratic island could quickly spread
to japan's southern islands tokyo's
front line of defense okay ishigaki will
not be the first of the ryukyu islands
to be armed with missiles in fact it
would be the fourth but it is important
because of all the islands that would
have japanese missile bases it is
closest to mainland china and don't
think for a moment that this plan is new
the idea of fortifying ishigaki with
missiles has been brewing in the minds
of the japanese government since 2017
and now china's increasingly aggressive
provocative campaign in the east china
sea and taiwan strait has finally moved
the japanese government to take the
plunge the idea is to create a kind of
wall of islands fortified with missiles
capable of repelling a hypothetical
chinese invasion of japan's south
western islands now think about it for a
moment if a country that has colonized
you in the past announces that it's
going to place missiles a few kilometers
from your shores it would be reasonable
to protest especially if we take into
account how suspicious they are about
territorial issues in this part of the
world right in fact that's exactly what
any other former japanese colony would
do well no not in this case behind
closed doors the taiwanese authorities
have celebrated this as a diplomatic
victory but in addition to the major
plan to install missiles in ishigaki
there is still more
as we have already covered in our
regular bulletin to our supporters on
patreon surprisingly and despite china's
extending tentacles taiwan has more and
more friends all over the world and the
truth is that many powers are already
moving in directions that are annoying
for china such as asking for taiwan to
be included as a member of the who which
is exactly what was agreed at the last
g7 but there are specific countries that
are making more than discrete gestures
towards taiwan obviously we're talking
about japan look at this
japan removes taiwan from china map in
defense white paper
in a warning to china japan's new
strategy paper mentions taiwan for the
first time
japan's deputy defense minister says
taiwan must be protected as a democratic
country yes incredible as it may seem to
us japan is positioning itself as the
only force in east asia seemingly
willing to stand up to china a position
that could be strengthened if japan
finally changes its pacifist
constitution which obliges it is not to
intervene abroad although that remains
to be seen but it doesn't end there
many international media outlets have
echoed a debate that is going on in the
japanese parliament a law on relations
with taiwan of their own and as you see
specifically the taiwan relations act
passed in 1979 by the united states when
the united states came to recognize the
people's republic of china to the
detriment of the republic of china is
taken as a reference among other things
the act served to establish strong
unofficial relations including virtually
diplomatic relations with the de facto
american embassy a special relationship
regulated by law something that japan
lacks a day in addition remember that
this u.s law also speaks in terms of
defense specifically section 2b4 states
the following
it is the policy of the united states to
consider any effort to determine the
future of taiwan by other than peaceful
means including by boycotts or embargoes
a threat to the peace and security of
the western pacific area and of grave
concern to the united states section 2
b4 of the taiwan relations act obviously
we don't know whether the idea of the
japanese legislators pushing for a bill
similar to this one includes
incorporating the field of military
defense or boycotts and sanctions
against china but what it certainly does
seek is to establish a much closer
relationship with taiwan to the
detriment of china and that's quite a
game changer with beijing
[Music]
together the two countries could become
the spearhead of a new pro-democracy
wave in the region with enough resources
to attract other countries and contain
the growing presence of china
particularly if we take into account the
ties with the united states and its
economic and technological influence
without going any further the combined
investment of both countries in r d is
close to 250 billion a year at the
moment the first big change may be
taiwan's entry into the cptpp the heir
to the trans-pacific trade agreement
that the united kingdom has recently
applied to join and which is led
precisely by japan
tsai lays out road map for taiwan to
join cptpp who would have thought it
passive japan beginning to lead an
apparent retaining wall to curb
beijing's ambitions of course all this
opens up another debate can japan really
intensify its relations with taiwan
without jeopardizing its huge economic
ties with china are we perhaps facing
the first example in asia of tough talk
against xi jinping's national
imperialist policies these are not minor
questions in fact this is precisely the
debate both in japan and in the united
states itself should we use a tough hand
against xi jinping for now you can leave
us your opinion in the comments and you
know if you found this video interesting
don't forget to like it and subscribe to
visualpolitik all the best see you next
time
[Music]